(upbeat music)
- Happy Tuesday.
- Oh, um, actually.
- You're on a clen...
- Pregnant.
- Nant. Pregnant.
That's what I said.
You're pregnant.
Oh my God!
I have a designated driver
for the next nine months.
- You sure do.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- That is so scary.
Am I allowed to move?
What do you mean Tom Ford
doesn't make onesies?
As long as you don't cry, poop or pee
before mom gets back, we got this.
(baby cries)
Okay, okay.
We're not gonna cry.
Oh.
Okay.
It's okay.
(sighs)
(baby cries)
Oh.
Oh no.
She's so sad.
I'm so sorry this play
date's over already.
I can't believe it just flew by.
I packed everything for you.
Ugh.
I'm not ready for a dog.
Traffic was so bad and I'm so sorry.
- You've got something there.
- Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's spit up.
- Oh okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's definitely spit up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If you're sure.
- Did you guys think that it's?
Okay, it's not that.
Oh my God, you're getting so big.
Linus has just been so bad at...
Oh my God.
Has she done that before?
- No.
- These are her first steps.
- Yeah, the first steps.
- These are her first actual steps.
Okay, okay.
We got this.
Oh my gosh, she's like a little person.
Go, go, go.
Oh, no, no, no.
- Oh, yeah, okay.
- Nope, nope.
Okay.
All right.
I think you just.
You gotta just bend the knees.
It's like these trays should
come off or something.
The toast is like a loofah.
(cries)
You know, I saw your first poop.
So, you're not the only
person with leverage.
(cries)
I am so sad that this is ending right now.
You are getting so big.
I cannot believe it.
(babbles in jibberish)
Hey, this is so fun.
Hey, ooh.
Do you play with your heart.
And the little mermaid
decided to not give up
her talent for someone else and realized
that she didn't need a
man to tell her anything.
The end.
That is the important part of that book.
And go, "Boo."
- Boo.
- That's how you throw shade.
One more time, okay?
One, one more time.
Oh gross.
- One more time.
- We just did one more time.
Swipe right.
No, swipe right, he was cute.
Oh, I can't get that one back.
(laughs)
Oh, Uncle Dan's gonna die alone.
Your mom's gonna be here soon.
I kinda wish you didn't have to leave.
Do you want me to call your mom
and see if you can spend the night?
Sleepover?
- Yes.
- Yeah.